sagen herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute
live und ihren leistungen zu aktuellen
ereignissen und diskussionen und dann
müssen wir feststellen dass auch im
jahre 2021 hass nachrichten drohungen
oder aufrufe zu gewalt immer noch zum
alltag im internet gehören immer noch
dann ist es nach wie vor ziemlich
schwierig täter innen zu finden
ausfindig zu machen gerade wenn sie
anonym gepostet haben ein neues gesetz
sollte das eigentlich ändern das ist
letztes jahr durch den bundestag
gegangen und dann ist ja normalerweise
das prozedere geht es durch den
bundesrat an den bundespräsidenten aber
genau da hat es gehakt warum das
blockiert wurde besprechen wir später
noch mal genauer im detail aber erstmal
müssen wir feststellen es gibt immer
noch keine wirklich guten gesetzlichen
regelungen zumindest ist das die kritik
und die leidtragenden sind eben die
menschen die jeden tag mit hass
nachrichten und pro messages bombardiert
werden und sich diesen müll angucken
müssen
mit zwei von denen wollen wir heute
reden einer mit diana zu lösen könnt ihr
auf youtube mit sicherheit als
interviewerin als unternehmerin als
buchautorin und mit carlotta brachte er
es ja eigentlich gesundheitsexperte aber
seither corona pandemie ist er auch
experte im anzeigen von beleidigungen
und von drohungen mit denen sprechen wir
gleich über ihre erfahrungen und danach
möchten wir reden genau über dieses
gesetz mit ricarda lang die ist
stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende und
frauenpolitische sprecherin von bündnis
90/die grünen und kennst dich genau in
diesem bereich ziemlich gut aus mit
ihren wir diskutieren warum es immer
noch so schwierig ist den hass im netz
einzudämmen und auch die
verantwortlichen zu finden
fragen die kommentare wie immer sehr
gerne und ich hoffe möglichst sachlich
und eben nichts zum thema passend
entweder in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten zu ihrer linken rechten
oder nach unten oder als e mail an uns
hätte er heute - la asset zdf.de und ich
gucke dann was ich davon rein nehmen
kann aber die erste frage die ich an
meine gast diana zu hilfen in berlin
stellen möchte ist gehören harz
kommentare eigentlich zwangsläufig zum
influenza rat war sein dazu also ich
würde sagen mittlerweile schon ich habe
mich auch daran irgendwie gewöhnt ich
mache das jetzt seit ungefähr
tatsächlich zehn jahren dass ich dinge
ins internet stelle und vor allem auch
seitdem ich mich mehr politischen themen
widmen
kann ich auch verstehen dass sich der
hass und auch wirklich jetzt zunehmend
wütende nachrichten eben immer im
postfach von mehr haben also das war
tatsächlich so eine zäsur politische
äußerungen und dann ging es ab aber war
es früher besser also als das quasi bei
dir vor allem um mode und kosmetik ging
also ich würde sagen da gibt es
natürlich auch andere themen die dann
kritisiert werden oder auch natürlich
aktuell zur krone situation wird eben da
auch sehr viel kritisiert oder man wird
eben auch immer ich meine influenza
innen sind ja auch nur menschen und das
ist leider auch manchmal nicht so leicht
wenn man eben jeden fehler den man
vielleicht auch macht weil es menschlich
ist in der öffentlichkeit macht und dass
ich dann eben menschen herausnehmen
überein als person zu urteilen und
wirklich sehr verletzte nachrichten dann
hinterlassen so dass sie natürlich auch
jeder andere lesen kann aber man selbst
wird auch natürlich sehr hart von den
verschiedensten worten dann getroffen
die altvorderen erst einen shitstorm
oder hast du ich glaube das war auch so
mit 16 17 aber ich hatte im letzten jahr
zum beispiel auch ein shitstorm und ich
würde sagen wenn ich jetzt auch wieder
daran zurück denke kriege ich direkt
bauchschmerzen wenn einfach das ganze
postfach voller hass nachrichten
geflutet ist und man eben als junge frau
auch nicht weiß wie man damit umgehen
soll wenn man einfach einen fehler
gemacht hat was macht man dann also was
machst du dann gehst du dann los und
sagt bitte freund freundin mitarbeiterin
einmal den ganzen schrott löschen ich
bin für drei tage weg und kommen dann
wieder oder klappt das gar nicht so gut
also es klappt natürlich nicht so gut
dem zu entfliehen denn was einmal im
internet ist das kann man natürlich auch
nicht wirklich entfernt man kann
natürlich versuchen kommentare zu
moderieren
aber das geht auch eben nur in einem
gewissen ausmaß und gerade wenn den
menschen wirklich unzählige nachrichten
verfassen
ist es eben sehr schwer das zu managen
und kam ja kann man dann wirklich denen
ich einfach her werden
es gibt ja leute die sorgen würden ja
dann
einfach drüber hinwegsehen handy
weglegen aber so einfach ist das ja
häufig nicht mehr
also ich würde auch sagen zb bei meinem
shitstorm der von einem jahr war da habe
ich auf jeden fall auch einen fehler
begangen und ich hab dann auch wirklich
versucht das aufzuarbeiten was natürlich
aber auch dann eben nicht immer alle
direkt sehen und man natürlich trotzdem
ständig damit konfrontiert wird und es
ist eben schon sehr belastend also vor
allem wirklich diese zeit wenn man auch
ja als mensch erst mal zeit braucht
bestimmte inhalte dinge zu verdauen und
sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
und wenn ein permanent man als mensch so
verurteilt wird
das ist eben schon nicht so einfach und
da hilft es mir schon auch erstmal in
gewissem abstand von social media zu
gewinnen aber irgendwann muss man ja
auch wieder dann zurückkehren
das ist ja auch letztendlich dann
berufen da kannst du nicht sagen so ich
lass das jetzt sein und suche mir was
anderes
genau so und deswegen würde ich sagen
habe ich mittlerweile schon versucht ja
im umgang damit zu finden
ich kann fast von glück sprechen dass
ich nur von digitaler gewalt regelmäßig
betroffen bin
aber das mich noch nicht eben in mein
privates umfeld verfolgt hat aber es ist
eben etwas wo man auch nicht auf pause
drücken kann man kann einfach da nicht
abschalten und ich will auch sagen das
hat gar nicht auch immer nur was mit
einer reichweite zu tun ich sehe das
auch viel bei meiner community ich habe
viele frauen im alter auch 18 bis 24
oder älter oder auch einige jünger die
eben auch von digitaler gewalt bedroht
sind und viele wissen ja auch oft da
nicht wer ist denn der eigentliche
absender und das macht eben vielen
jungen menschen natürlich angst was
sagst du den song gibt es dort tipps
wenn du binden die sich auch manchmal
hilfe suchen dann durch genau also ich
gerne kann dem natürlich auch nicht
immer herr werden ich empfehle dann
immer zum beispiel plattformen wie hate
wenn man zum beispiel auch selbst was
wie ein dick bekommt oder eben andere
pass nachrichten kann man eben auch
dagegen vorgehen
man kann das auch zur anzeige bringen
und wenn so was natürlich öfters
passiert dann sollte man das eben auch
machen und manchmal kann man eben nicht
wissen ob es immer auch die gleiche
person ist weil es natürlich auf zb
instagram so einfach ist auch
verschiedene fake profile zu erstellen
so dass man dann als person eben
wirklich mich genau weiß ist das jetzt
ein hater dem man hat oder eine person
die wirklich etwas gegen ein hut oder
sind das auch mehrere das macht es
natürlich gar nicht so einfach immer
dagegen auch vorzugehen um sich dann
auch wieder sicher zu fühlen
das würde doch gerade fragen wo siehst
du denn die netzwerke die plattform dar
in der verantwortung tun die da genug
oder ist da noch luft nach oben
also ich würde sagen die plattform
helfen auf jeden fall schon dass man als
content catering sich da auch ein
bisschen sicherer fühlen kann man kann
eben bestimmte profile blockieren oder
auch quasi unsichtbar machen aber ich
habe eben leute ja es ist viel an zum
arbeiten muss jedes profil anschauen
also das kann man zum beispiel macht man
kann auch wörter eben sagen wir solisten
dass man wenn jemand das kommentiert
dass man das nicht mehr schreiben kann
das kann aber soweit ich weiß eigentlich
jeder machen aber das reicht halt
manchmal nicht ich glaube man muss da
wirklich versuchen ja vor allem wenn
dann wirklich ganz tiefgründige
diskussion im entstehen oder sehr nah
verletzende dann wird man eben einfach
nicht mehr her dass zu managen
ich finde es aber sehr schwer jetzt
herauszufinden inwieweit da wirklich die
plattform auch immer die verantwortung
komplett tragen müssen
gibst du dir so ein so eine art profil
des typischen trotz oder haters oder ist
es tatsächlich vom 12 bis 62 alles durch
also ich würde sagen ein typisches hater
profil erkennt man auch daran dass die
leute natürlich kein profilbild haben
und ebenso unkenntlich sind wie es nur
geht also dass man halt eben gar kein ja
gar nicht herausfinden kann eben wer
jetzt da wirklich den schatz hinterlässt
also ich greife auch oft feministische
themen auf also ich spreche mich eben
für gleichberechtigung aus und selbst da
kann ich auch gar nicht sagen das ist
egal von wem das kommt es fühlt sich
eben immer mehr menschen verletzt aber
dann ist es natürlich mittlerweile so
leicht einfach ein fake profil zu
erstellen und auch seine wut und sein
hass dazu lassen und dann mit anderen
weiter wirklich auch zu helfen und auch
bei anderen kollegin von mir geht es
aber auch mancher so weit dass ich
wirklich menschen online zusammentun um
gegen influenza zu helfen wirklich auch
negative kommentare kritiken dazu lassen
und das ist wirklich also das macht mich
einfach unglaublich traurig und wütend
zugleich
da ist auch menschen so viel zeit damit
verbringen zu schaffen im netz ich sehe
gerade mal ich guck mal die kommentare
auf youtube und ich sehe da auch vor
allem würde ich mal sagen unwissenheit
also ein christ kommentiert also ein
dick blick finde ich persönlich jetzt
nicht mit hass verbunden
das ist zwar irgendwo richtig aber auch
irgendwie nicht denn ein dick würde ich
jetzt persönlich als sexuelle
belästigung und von daher als form von
digitaler gewalt einschätzen oder wie
siehst du das genau also das ist eben
auch eine form von digital gewalt wenn
einem menschen einfach solche bilder zu
senden
das kann natürlich auch für viele eben
ja unglaublich verstören seien vor allem
auch für ganz junge menschen wenn man
sowas einfach in seinem postfach findet
und da sollte man dann eben auch
eventuell gegen vorgehen wenn man das
regelmäßig zum beispiel bekommt oder
wenn man das einfach nicht mehr möchte
die aber vielen dank bis hierhin wir
sprechen gleich weiter mit der und
unserem nächsten gast denn dass
politiker innen angegangen werden ist
nichts neues das gehört so ein bisschen
wird zum jobprofil bislang waren das vor
allem entweder die politikerinnen die
ganz vorne stehen in der ersten reihe
oder wie sich um so themen wie
gleichberechtigung migration
rechtsextremismus sich damit beschäftigt
haben aber der groner krise geht das
auch für gesundheitspolitik das ist
seitdem ein gefährliches pflaster an
seinem stern berichtet
hass und hetze im netz ganz besonders
oft ganz besonders enthält es wird
beleidigt gedroht offen aufgerufen zum
mord zu beobachten vor allem auch gerade
jetzt in der virus krise blinde wut
entlädt sich da beispielsweise in den
kommentaren gegen karl lauterbach spd
gesundheitsexperte
[Musik]
es trifft politiker und viele andere
prominente influenza es kann jeden
treffen wer sich aufhält auf twitter
facebook instagram und anderen
plattformen kommt an hassan lügen an
gewalt aufrufen kaum noch vorbei von
einer neuen dimension der verbalen
brutalität spricht etwa karl lauterbach
der hass und hetze im netz derzeit
erlebt ganz besonders oft und ganz
besonders
enthemmt und die begrüße ich jetzt auch
bei uns im stream herzlich willkommen
herr lauterbach wann ist denn das bei
ihnen richtig unangenehm geworden
also es gab schon mal an der erste welle
von also ich was sehr unangenehm
empfunden habe im späten sommer als ich
vor einer zweiten welle gewarnt habe und
das wetter war gut die fallzahlen waren
noch niedrig und da hat man das einfach
als störend empfunden da hatte ich also
ordentlich zu kämpfen mit den
sogenannten trier denkern und also
rechten plattformen die die querdenker
entweder unterstützt haben oder genutzt
haben was auch immer aber da gab es eine
heftige welle von hass hat aber dann
nachher nachgelassen ist weniger
geworden weil die zweite welle ist dann
ja gekommen und da haben dann sehr viele
gesehen okay es ist tatsächlich echt
also wir kriegen noch mal ein problem
das war keine reine leere drohung oder
spielverderber sondern wir haben eine
zweite werde es gefährlich jetzt ist das
plötzlich wieder sehr stark ausgefallen
das hat offensichtlich damit zu tun dass
wir jetzt noch einmal den lockdown
verlängern mussten das mittlerweile
außerdem mutationen also tatsächlich ihn
an der dritte wählen können und davor
habe ich natürlich auch waren dann
müssen was epidemiologe bin ich nicht
allein da es aber anders gemacht und wir
haben hat den grenzwert von 50 500
200.000 pro woche herunter gesetzt und
da ist noch mal so eine richtige welle
losgegangen ab der mitte der letzten
woche jetzt auch in den letzten tagen
ich will mich da nicht das so als einzel
opfer stilisieren das wäre völlig falsch
sind auch andere betroffen
das betrifft zum beispiel auch
wissenschaftler damit bringt man
beispielsweise ich glaube auch christian
drosten bekommt eine menge mit und
daraus natürlich politiker die also
diese vorschläge mit vertreten müssen
aber es ist schon jetzt an der zweite
schwere hast werde losgegangen
die in ihrer wortwahl und auch im
volumen schon also bedenklich ist haben
sie das gefühl dass sind konzertierte
aktion oder sind das lauter einzeltäter
innen
ich bin da kein experte so kann das
nicht wirklich beurteilen das machen im
wesentlichen dass die monitore also
dieser foren das machen entweder also
sehr gute gruppen die das machen also
den ich auch danke wie die zum beispiel
die insider dann macht das mein team
ich lese natürlich selbst die kommentare
zum beispiel auch bitter weil ich oft
auch kommentare ganz gezielt ein dart
und davon auch etwas lernen ich möchte
einfach die stimmung im land mitbekommen
und da sind dann tatsächlich auch diese
kommentare dabei wenn ich das war ein
kommentar erkennen ließ sich
systematisch nicht weiter und wie aus
jenigen die das also veranlasst haben
oder machen die werden dann blockiert
aber ich bekomme einiges mit und ich
bekomme es natürlich auch mit war die
bringen die kommentare die sonst also
drohungen und beleidigungen die an
bestimmten werten beschallten die
bringen wir konsequent zur anzeige und
ich muss natürlich die anzeigen gegen
zeichnen ich muss mich mit in allen
zeitungen beschäftigen soldaten werden
und dann komme ich auch immer wieder sah
man hinweise von ermittlern die dann
etwas aufgedeckt haben und strafanzeige
erstatten wollen in meinem namen und war
somit also bin ich damit mehr
konfrontiert als ich will das läuft
mittlerweile so viel über meine
schreibtische dass ich das gefühl habe
also dass das schon mehr geworden ist
deutlich mehr geworden ist und auch eine
andere qualität bekommen hat das
enthemmte aus
haben sie noch einen überblick darüber
wie viele strafverfahren sie gerade am
laufen haben nein habe ich wirklich
nicht
also das ist ja sein das ist dass er
sich eine menge und das ist mir am
freitag das habe ich ja auch da noch
fitter geschehen ich bin am freitag zu
später stunde bin ich noch mal durch die
büros gegangen mein team war weg da habe
ich einfach mal geguckt was liegt auf
den schattigen getaner arbeit man
wirklich auf jeden schlagen also in
drucksachen also von ermittlern behörden
also von staatsanwalt korrespondenz mit
staatsanwaltschaften also screenshots
und so weiter und so fort
also auf jedem start ich meine team
mitarbeiter belags quasi ermittlungs
zeit beleidigungs zeit das ist also das
hat schon andere dimension am haus waren
wir nicht so klar
wir haben danach auch dann eine
teambesprechung gehabt und also das
wurde mir dann auch bestätigt man die
melder ist ein stück weit von mir weg
aber ich sehe dass ich auch eine menge
und mir war nicht da geworden wie viel
ist mittlerweile ist ja so wenn ich hier
bei uns in die kommentare kugel muss ich
feststellen dass sieht nicht besonders
besser aus also mir schreibt mein team
gerade im hintergrund also wir haben
hier viele sexistische beleidigungen und
kommentare oder auch den üblichen ich
sage heute den üblichen hass gegen sie
herr lauterbach diana hast du denn schon
mal überhaupt mit dem gedanken gespielt
solche menschen zur anzeige zu bringen
also ich hatte jetzt hat sich auch schon
mal überlegt aber tatsächlich bin ich
jetzt noch nicht gegen einen täter oder
hass kommentar vorgegangen aber auch
tatsächlich so ein bisschen aus der
angst heraus wenn man das dann eben
regelmäßig macht das ist natürlich ein
großer aufwand ist und dass man sich
eben ja auch wie hält aber schon sagte
andauernd damit auch weiterhin befassen
muss und das macht es natürlich dann
auch eben weiterhin sehr schmerzhaft
das heißt also dann lieber die methode
das versuchen nicht weiter zu beachten
und herr lauterbach tendiert eher dazu
dann nachzugehen was versprechen sie
sich davon herr lauterbach dass sie
diese ganzen anzeigen geschrieben haben
also es ist zunächst für mich einfach
eine sache des prinzips also wir leben
in einem rechtsstaat und ich möchte dass
du etwas angezeigt wird also so dass auf
jedem anderen empfehlen das zu tun wir
können das ja nicht stehen lassen das
ist schon also aus meiner sicht an
wichtiges grundprinzip dass die dinge
weil die also strafrechtlich verfolgt
werden müssen dass die dass dort auch
die ermittlungen veranlasst werden von
daher also kann ich nicht gesetze machen
die bürgerschützen sollen also nehme
aber selbst diese schutzrechte arzt
bürger nicht wahr und ich muss da ja
auch so auch zudem war sich anderen
empfehlen muss ich stehen das ist ganz
klar dass ich so was nicht für jeden das
muss sich jeder tun aber für mich ist
das anfahren der sache der konsequenz
das verspreche ich mir davon und ich
glaube dass auch der ein oder andere
empfindliche strafen bekommen hat das
ist zumindest was ich so aus
ermittlerkreisen mitbekommen
und das ist aus meiner sicht auch
richtig dann können sie das
nachvollziehen dass jemand wie diana zu
lesen dann sagte ich möchte mich damit
jetzt nicht mehr beschäftigen ich möchte
denen keine aufmerksamkeit schenken und
ist es natürlich auch eine sache von
zeit und geld
das ist ganz klar das kann ich gut
verstehen
es gibt allerdings ja auch gott sei dank
hilfsorganisationen wie hate aids die
das dann für eine torwand ich habe die
nicht in anspruch genommen jetzt aber
dass wir dann eine empfehlung für
menschen die aus einmal im rampenlicht
stehen und das nicht selbst machen
wollen dass man das also sozusagen an
solche aus meiner sicht sehr ihr und
werden also angels also delegiert dass
die das für eine nacht und ich habe aber
volles verständnis wenn man es nicht
machen will
gerne macht das niemand und ich habe ja
eben schon darauf hingewiesen
ich bin ja auch ein stück privilegiert
weil ein großer teil der vorarbeiten
wird von einem team gemacht und wir
haben natürlich durch die
bundestagspolizei auch ein erstklassiges
ermittlungsteam dann möchte ich mich
auch bedanken uns an dieser stelle bka
und also egal wer ihn aber auch hier die
polizei des bundestags sind schon also
truppen auf die wir uns sehr verlassen
können ich bin ja eigentlich ein freund
davon fragen aus dem publikum aus der
zuschauerschaft mit in den betrieben
einzubinden leider sehe ich hier keine
wirklich fragen die uns wirklich
weiterbringen würden ich kann nur
weitergeben
es gibt auch zuspruch herr lauterbach an
ihrer adresse gute arbeit herr
lauterbach weiter so schreibt michael
sturm auf facebook oder susanne heine
sagte schrecken wie die menschen
teilweise reagieren das ist doch einfach
nur ehrlich wird auch andrea s
auf youtube bedankt sich bei ihnen für
ihre arbeit also es gibt auch das ist es
uns wichtig dass auch mal zu betonen
aber wir haben sie beide auch gebeten so
ein paar kommentaren mitzubringen und
vorzulesen wenn sie die gerade zur hand
haben vielleicht fängt die einmal an
also das ist natürlich auch immer nicht
so schön die direkt erfolgt zu lesen
aber zb hier natürlich auch viele
vorurteile wenn es um feminismus geht
oder selbst das deute über meinen körper
urteilen den kleinen brüste sind
widerlich steht hier oder hier schaut
dann auch jemand es ist keine kritik
sondern die wahrheit dass frauen mit
kleinen brüsten er zum feminismus
tendieren hätte sie eine größere
oberweite weite würde sie nicht zum
feminismus tendieren oder hier dauerte
lernt der feministen tour sie das ist
jetzt nur entwickelt ja also man merkt
doch das ist eher schwerfällig bereits
grad fast zu wissen dass wir darum
gebeten haben danke trotzdem dafür aber
es bewirkt dass dann auch bei dir dass
du dann sagt okay dann las ich das thema
sein oder ich habe keine lust mich dazu
zu äußern weil da kommt immer wieder
zurück
also es geht ich versuche dann eben
schon immer ein bisschen die kommentare
zu managen oder hab da auch schon im
auch unterstützung aber wie gesagt das
reicht eben gar nicht da fast nur eine
person zu haben gerade bei
innenpolitischen themen auch wenn es
selbst um sensible themen geht wie
schwangerschafts abbrüche oder ich und
auch leisten was zum thema misogynie
gemacht also es gibt irgendwie immer was
natürlich wo dann auch themen die ich
behandele auf mich dann reflektiert
werden und da ist es eben wie gesagt
nicht immer sogleich dem ja dann herr zu
werden
das glaubst du sind warum schreiben
menschen und das vor allem
wahrscheinlich männer in seinem fall
solche kommentare ich glaube eine sache
ist natürlich dass man jetzt vor allem
zb auf instagram hat man ja auch keine
klarnamen pflicht das heißt man kann
eben ganz leicht mal seine meinung
rauslassen und irgendwie auch sein hut
und seinen frust und ich glaube das
machen eben sehr viele dass sie das so
als ventil nutzen das heißt du bist dann
der punching ball für die frustration
von manchen männern
es ist bei ihnen ähnlicher lauterbach
das gefühl haben sie müssen jetzt hier
als punchingball herhalten für die
politik der bundesregierung
ich glaube das ist nicht ganz so bei mir
die leute die sich bei mir so aus dass
die haben mich schon dass also zählt
auch identifiziert und die sind dafür
mit dem was ich vortage und meine
position also sind sie nicht
einverstanden und lassen das klar aus
das sind oft krone leutner querdenker
rechte also die also ganz gezielt auf
personen ein problem haben und es ist
weniger die regierungen versehen
nichtsdestotrotz also damit muss ich
klarkommen leben ich möchte auch nicht
den eindruck erwecken dass ich den
ganzen tag darüber nachdenken
eines muss hier ganz klar gesagt werden
also bevor wir respekt haben müssen und
was mich auch tatsächlich besorgt ist
die entwicklung der pandemie also mich
also besorgt wirklich also mich hier
besorgen die mutationen ich besorgt eine
mögliche dritte welle die wir vor uns
haben
mich besorgt so zu sagen dass wir das
hoffentlich das land so gut wie möglich
durch kommen und somit im vergleich zu
den schicken der pandemie sind diese
beschimpfungen der hast uns der schmutz
aus dem netz das ist für mich da im
vergleich also quasi relativ unbedeutend
unangenehm aber unbedeutend aber dass
konsumiert nicht viel zeit in meinem
tagesablauf sondern also die tatsächlich
die pandemie ist der schrecken nicht
diese verrückten das heißt sie lassen
sich davon auch nicht abbringen
weiterzumachen
davon kann definitiv keine rede sein das
ich kann ihnen versichern was ich auch
nie darüber nachdenken wenn ich
irgendetwas sage oder wenn ich etwas
formuliere
mir gefällt das den querdenker weil wie
gefällt das den täter an dem netz also
ich versichere ihnen das könnte mir
nicht legaler sein also an dem punkt ich
definitiv noch nicht angekommen dass es
meine arbeit beeinflussen würde
an dem punkt aber auch ich finde man
sollte schon eben sagen wie auch im
kreis vor allem auch digitale gewalt
wirklich auf die mentale gesundheit
eingehen kann und ich glaube natürlich
als politiker in oder als im finsteren
ist man da betroffen aber eben auch
andere menschen
haben corona leugner in ihre familien
ihrer familie sehen sich auch oft eben
damit konfrontiert und ich glaube das
darf man eben auch nicht unterschätzen
dass jeder immer so ein bisschen auch
dagegen ankämpft und nicht alle kommen
so leicht damit auch klar ich glaube
lauterbach sie haben sich seinen letzten
30 jahren als politiker wahrscheinlich
schon ein dickes fell zugelegt oder kann
man das lernen nochmals lernen kann weiß
ich nicht aber auf jeden fall was bleibt
am ball was übrig und ich glaube dass
ich da also für viele spreche es ist
trotzdem genau was frau von löwen gesagt
hat also für uns auch wichtig dass wir
darauf achten
ich möchte dass wir das zum thema machen
und aufgreifen dass wir anzeigen
erstatten und also daran arbeiten das
machen wir ja auch zum schutz derer die
sich viel weniger schützen können als
wir
man muss ja ehrlicherweise zugeben wenn
ich das wollte wenn die proben zu nehmen
da können sich jederzeit mit
personenschutz auftreten
wir werden relativ gut geschützt und ich
habe natürlich auch viel erfahrung im
umgang mit solchen bedrohungslagen es
gibt aber sehr viele menschen die all
dies nicht haben und also für die machen
wir das ja auch und für die werden wir
auf solche gespräche wie wir sie heute
abend haben geführt es kann also hier
nicht um den privilegierten politiker
gehen sondern hier muss es so man ganz
grundsätzliches phänomen gehen hass im
netz ist also etwas was langfristig sehe
zersetzend für die demokratie wirken
kann
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen beiden für
diese wichtige diskussion dass sie so
offen und ehrlich waren darüber zu reden
über ein für manche schwierigeres thema
für manche ein wichtiges thema auf jeden
fall ein thema über das wir weiterreden
müssen das hier in vielen dank wir
möchten jetzt nämlich weiter über die
politische diskussion reden cook aber
noch mal gas geben uns in die kommentare
und stelle einfach fest es ist es ist
echt ein bisschen traurig mit euch muss
ich heute sagen also ruft dazu auf dass
ihr euch benimmt und ich lese einfach
viele unschöne sachen aber da müssen wir
durch gut also die große frage ist kann
auch sowas nicht gesetzlich besser
geregelt werden haben wir nicht mehr
handhabe es gibt viele bemühungen ist es
aber alles ziemlich kompliziert und an
seinen stern fast das mal ganz kurz für
uns zusammen
das gesetz gegen hasskriminalität ist
bereits verabschiedet vom bundestag mit
einem klaren ziel sagte damals im
dezember 2009 10 die
bundesjustizministerin
künftig gilt wer im netz hetzt und droht
der wird härter der wird effektiver
verfolgt doch das gesetz kann derzeit
nicht in kraft treten regierung und
opposition im bundesrat ringen um das
thema bestandsdaten also um die frage ob
die netzwerke nicht nur namen und
adressen der user sondern zb auch
passwörter an die
strafverfolgungsbehörden weitergeben
sollen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat hierzu
vorgaben gemacht wie die nun gesetzlich
umgesetzt werden darüber gibt es weiter
politischen streit über das problem
möchte ich jetzt reden mit ricarda lang
stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende und
frauen zwischen sprecherin von bündnis
90/die grünen hallo frau land bevor ich
jetzt mal mit in die diskussion
einsteigen möchte ich noch mal ganz kurz
was los werden worauf nicht meine
redaktion gerade hingewiesen hat es gab
nämlich auch für diana zu lösen
durchaus auch mut und positive
kommentare zum beispiel von johannes der
sagte respekt vor dem mut von frau zu
dürfen dass sie das gerade vorgelesen
hat und auch danke dass ihr das so offen
diskutiert ein kommentar von mp3 hat von
daher habe ich gerade wissen mit euch
geschimpft aber es gibt auch die anderen
kommentare so fraulein jetzt möchten wir
mal über die ganze politik dahinter
reden sie sind ja selber öfter auch
schon zur zielscheibe von hass
nachrichten geworden warum ist es jetzt
eigentlich so schwierig da gesetzlich
härter durchzugreifen um es eben auch
einfacher zu machen damit menschen
einfach sagen okay ich zeige dass jetzt
an weil ich keine angst habe dass da ein
langer prozess dahinter steckt so
schwierig ist es eigentlich gar nicht
wir als grüne haben schon sehr viele
vorschläge gemacht wie eine bessere
gesetzeslage schaffen können um hass im
netz nachverfolgbar zu machen und auch
um betroffene besser zu unterstützen
weil wir eben sehr laut aber habe es
gerade angesprochen die der hass im netz
sehen wir gerade erleben hat eine
demokratie zersetzende funktion gerade
weil sich auch viele menschen löwenteil
lauterbach
beispiel es nicht tun aber viele
menschen viele frauen aus dem netz
zurückziehen und sich damit aus und
demokratischen debatte zurückziehen wir
haben auch immer wieder vorschläge
gemacht wie man die bestehende
gesetzeslage als das netzwerk
durchsetzungs gesetz reformieren und
verbessern könnte was zb die rechte von
betroffenen angeht aber auch für
menschen wo unrechtmäßig was gelöscht
wurde
aber was die bundesregierung jetzt mit
ihrem aktuellen gesetzesentwurf gemacht
hat also der verknüpfung von dem hass im
netz mit dem bestandsdaten auskunft zur
reparatur gesetzen bisschen an bord
ungetüm ist es den vorschlag vorgelegt
hat der ziemlich wahrscheinlich nicht
verfassungsgemäß ist
wer nicht den anforderungen von
karlsruhe als vom
bundesverfassungsgericht genügt gerade
was die sensible frage von passwörtern
angeht weil das ist das ist alles sehr
komplex ein bisschen glaube ich ein
bisschen sortieren also wenn sie einmal
sagen sie haben schon vorschläge gemacht
wie es einfacher ginge sei nochmal einen
konkreten vorschlag wo man sagen kann ok
das ist wirklich so tauglich dass jeder
der computer bedienen kann auch
hinkriegt ja also was wir sehr klar
brauchen ist zum einen dass es ganz
genaue regelungen dafür gibt wie melde
auskunftsverfahren gestaltet sein muss
als das ist für jeden auffindbar und
einfach durchführbar ist dass sie
nämlich erstmal durch den ganzen wust
von irgendwelchen zeiten durch firma
durchbringen muss dass es klare
sanktionsmechanismen gibt gegen
plattformen facebook twitter etc
wenn sie nicht den gesetzen sprechen
also wenn sie in fällen wo gelöscht
werden müsste nicht löschen
und in dem es in dem fall wenn es von
mir gelöscht wurde wovon ich davon
ausgeht dass das nicht rechtmäßig war
ich mich an so eine cleansing stelle
enden kann als eine stelle die mir
indirekt unterstützung gibt und diesen
fall schlichtet das während konkrete
verbesserungsvorschläge zu den regeln
die wir schon haben
insgesamt musste das ziel aus meiner
sicht sein dass wir davon wegkommen die
meisten regelungen die hand von großen
plattform anbieten also damit
gewinnorientierte unternehmen zu geben
die darüber entscheiden in welchem falls
sie löschen wie man sich melden kann wie
man sich beschweren kann und sehr viel
stärker diese regeln demokratisch
politisch festzulegen aber wer soll so
eine clearingstelle
wer soll die stellen also soll das ist
dass eine bundesbehörde was stellen sie
sich davor
genau das könnte man zum beispiel am
innenministerium an tun ich glaube die
ganz genaue anknüpfen es gar nicht die
relevante stelle aber es müsste eine
politische stelle ist das sagen sein die
dann auch eine rechtsdurchsetzung also
sozusagen die kraft haben einen ganz tag
nicht ins private verlagert werden
jetzt kommen zu dem gesetz was die
bundesregierung letztes jahr durch den
bundestag gebracht hat vielleicht können
sie ganz kurz erklären was da dass der
mechanismus dahinter ist also wie ist
das gedacht also dieses gesetz zu sagen
noch mal vor wann daten auskunft von den
plattformen an den gesetzgeber und auch
an rechts verfolgungsbehörden direkt
durchsetzung behörden und
verfolgungsbehörden gehen soll
und da ist zb die frage ob auch
passwörter freigegeben werden kann was
wir sehr klar ablehnen würden weil das
campen massive eingriff und aus unserer
sicht auch nicht verfassungsgemäße
eingriff in die rechte von userinnen ist
und durch die verknüpfung von teilweise
auf sinnvollen vorschlägen bereich hass
im netz mit diesen teilweise nicht
verfassungsgemäßen vorschlägen wird
verhindert dass es ein gesetz gibt das
langfristig getroffene schützt ganz im
gegenteil müsste man davon ausgehen dass
es in ein bis zwei jahren castro wieder
einkassiert wird und damit die
betroffenen natürlich nicht geholfen
aber was ist denn genau daran nicht
verfassungsgemäß also es ist ja erst mal
doch der versuch möglichst schnell
herauszufinden wer hinter einem haus
kommentar steht wie ich ihnen leider
hier immer noch in unserem chat leser
genau das problem ist ja wenn der
zugriff auf passwörter gegeben werden da
hat ja einen hochsensiblen bereich und
das ist doch mit drei jahren lernt
gesetzt und nicht die vorgaben verfassen
ja okay also es reicht dann würde
eigentlich reichen zu sagen ich muss
wissen welche ip-adresse dieser mensch
hat und wie der sich jetzt hier meint
damit man das zuordnen kann
warum diese passwörter das müssten sie
die bundesregierung fragen ich bin ja
sozusagen die personen die das ihr
kritisierten andere vorschläge hat es
gibt ja durchaus andere vorschläge mich
zum beispiel einmal vorstellen dürfte es
gibt einen vorschlag ich war zu spüren
meyer kennen von der gesellschaft für
freiheitsrechte der auch ein vorschlag
gemacht hat dass man zum beispiel eine
langfristige sperrung von accounts ohne
dass es die
nachvollziehbarkeit gibt wiener nehmen
dahinter steht das sozusagen rechts
identität für accounts geschaffen wird
und sich dadurch langfristig gesperrt
werden können das wäre zum beispiel aus
meiner sicht ein sehr viel
verfassungsmäßigen sehr viel freiheit
und rechtsstaatlicher vorschlag der
umsetzbar wäre
was ich gerade gesagt haben wir haben
durchaus versucht hier mit der
bundesjustizministerin christen irland
recht zu sprechen die hatte leider keine
zeit heute abend deswegen können wir
diese frage nicht stellen
das problem ist ja schon länger bekannt
dass es nicht so einfach ist gerade
anonyme kommentatoren ausfindig zu
machen um dann zu wissen den man da
eigentlich anzeigen soll
aber auf der anderen seite das ist ja
auch etwas was die grünen immer sehr
hoch halten ist er die anonymität im
netz die gewahrt werden soll eben damit
es eine meinungsfreiheit gibt das ist
doch eigentlich ein paradox was sie da
wollen naja ich glaube in der realität
erlebt man immer wieder
widersprüchlichkeiten aber nicht immer
der größte hammer ist die beste an sport
und das sozusagen das sinnvollste moment
und worauf sie wahrscheinlich hinaus
wollen was ist tatsächlich aber auch in
dem bestehenden gesetz der
bundesregierung nicht drin ist was aber
immer wieder diskutiert wird ist eine
klarnamen pflicht also das sagen ich
muss sozusagen einen klaren nahmen auch
im auftritt haben das geht aber meiner
meinung nach teilweise ein problem
vorbei es gibt viele anonyme kommentare
das wurde gerade auch schon gespannt
geäußert aber auf jeden fall nicht
ausschließlich gerade da sich die hater
gerade dass die trolle so oft im recht
sehen erlebt ich es zum beispiel immer
wieder sich kommentare bekommen mit
sogar mord oder vergewaltigung strom
man schaut auf den account und da steht
jemand mit klarnamen und bild mit
labrador meinen arm und dem kind im
anderen arm weil die personen sich im
recht fühlt das heißt dafür wäre das
schon mal keine antwort und zweitens ist
die anonymität im netz jahren hoher wert
dass sowohl weil einmal regelungen die
wir treffen auch globalen international
gedacht werden müssen
das netz ist nichts was national
funktioniert und wenn ich ein
autoritäres starten schaue da zu sehen
wie wichtig auch eine anonymisierung
eures organisierung von zb
freiheitskämpfern im netz ist aber ich
kann es auch viel anschaulicher und
näher bei uns machen sie ihre
jugendliche im ländlichen raum die nicht
wollen dass ihre lehrerinnen
mitschülerin oder eltern mitbekommen wo
sich im netz aus
oben treiben als die angst vor
diskriminierung
das ist ein hoher wert das heißt die
aufgabe ist es regelungen zu finden die
diesen hohen wert trotzdem schätzt und
auch weiterhin erhält und trotzdem
bessere nachverfolgbarkeit und ein
beispiel habe ich ja klar genannt was
zum beispiel der debatte ist wäre diese
vorschlag dass man die rechte direkte
nachverfolgbarkeit von accounts und
sozusagen auch eine direkte sperrung von
accounts macht auf der anderen seite
also das ist dort gab es einfach immer
neuen trends ergeben
das hat gehört instagram ist einfach ne
genau die möglichkeit gibt es natürlich
die können wir nicht vollkommen
ausschließen
aber dann ist natürlich die frage und
das wäre gleich der zweite punkt fallen
wie schafft man die nachvollziehbarkeit
haben die strafbehörden dazu bringen
dass sie besser in der lage sind das
nachzuvollziehen
und hier sehen wir es an vielen fällen
auch nicht an der anonymität scheitert
sondern auch an dem wissen kompetenz an
der ausstattung innerhalb der straße
würden und auch einfach an denen an den
ressourcen die dafür vorhanden sind
jetzt habe ich eine frage die finde ich
tatsächlich ganz interessant weil sie
auch ein kernproblem fast wie
unterscheiden die grünen zwischen hass
und meinungen die ihnen nicht gefällt
also wo ziehen sie die grenze und kann
man hasst politisch verordneten
verordnen verorten
da es ist nicht wahrscheinlich dass es
für ordnung ich weiß es nicht okay also
immer die frage wo ist der unterschied
zwischen hass und meinungen die einen
nicht passt ja das ist eine sehr gute
frage und deshalb müssen wir glaube ich
auch aufpassen sich zum beispiel im
konkreten juristischen bereich gar nicht
mit dem begriff des hasses umgehen würde
sondern hier glaube ich sehr viel
sinnvoller der begriff der gewalt der
digitalen gewalt ist das heißt konkret
zu reden wo sprechen wir von
beleidigungen wo es ums konkrete
angriffe bedrohungen von einer person
das heißt es können zum beispiel um
konstruktive und sachliche kommentare
wenn mir jemand schreibt war die grünen
sind total blöd ich kann mit denen gar
nichts anfangen
das finde ich jetzt keine konstruktiven
beitrag zur debatte
das ist aber für mich kein hate speech
das ist kein hass kommentaren dass es
keine digitale gewalt wenn aber jemand
schreibt ricarda lang die dumme [ __ ]
was fällt dir eigentlich ein dass es
sozusagen direkt der komplette angriff
auf die person ehrverletzende
beleidigung das heißt die haben wir
sozusagen auch schon recht
straftatbestände von dem man ausgehen
kann man könnte eigentlich
ein bisschen überlegen es gibt ja
durchaus eine parallelität zwischen
analoger und digitaler welt wenn auf der
strassen wm etwas zurufen würde würde
ich sagen blöde kommentare oder bricht
sagen es ist eine beleidigung ähnliche
lage ist die gleichen sozusagen auf
strafrechtlichen nachstellungen netz
anlegen
das haben sie den hund eine lose seiten
frage ob sich der hass auf sich der hass
verorten lässt ich glaube nicht
ausschließlich als es gibt nicht hast
denn nur aus einer richtung kommt wir
sehen aber und dazu gab es zum beispiel
gerade nochmal reportagen letzten wochen
spiegellosen frauen hassen dass
insbesondere rechte kreise rechtsextreme
kreise auch oft angedockt an die afg an
demokratie verachtende organisationen
und parteien das ganz ganz viel hetze
gegenüber politikerin gegenüber frauen
im netz gegenüber migrantinnen aus
dieser reihe kommt das heißt wir müssen
die frage von hass im netz auch immer
mit sinnvollen strategien gegen den
rechtsextremismus zusammen denken sie
ist eine frage von sein gewissen auf
youtube es gibt doch bereits die
möglichkeit sich mit seinen perso im
internet auszuweisen wo ist denn das
problem kommentarspalten nur für
menschen mit personal dies zu öffnen
wäre das für sie eine lösung dafür
sozusagen wieder voraussetzen dass
eigentlich keine wirkliche anonymität im
netz gegeben ist und ich hatte gerade
begründet warum eben auch an die täten
wert hat innerhalb des netzes und das
wäre sozusagen ja auch dadurch er
ausgeliehen wird
aber so als anbieter könnte man doch für
sich entscheiden ok ich das hier nur
leute rein durch genau weiß wer da quasi
zu mir kommt oder also als privates
unternehmen kann man bauen will hat sich
zu entscheiden er von manchen genau die
möglichkeit gibt es das sollte man
sozusagen auch nicht verbieten das blatt
vorm das tun haben sie dann auch noch
müssen sie sich als dies infolge
gesetzlicher haben sie hoffnung dass wir
dieses phänomen doch irgendwie zumindest
in den griff kriegen oder zumindest ein
bisschen mehr runter fahren können auf
jeden fall ich bin da ich glaube auch
weil wir jetzt gerade das einzig gute
daran wie viel öffentliche debatte es
gerade im harz im netz geht weil immer
viele betroffene sich zu wort melden das
einst gute daran dass es diese debatte
gerade braucht ist ja dass sie auch ein
gesellschaftliches bewusstsein dafür
schärfen und ich glaube wir müssen
einfach schaffen müssen ist aus meiner
sicht einen dreiklang
zunahmen das erste ist die bessere
ausstattung ausbildung und aber auch
weiterbildung damit nicht nur junge neue
polizisten damit betraut sind von
polizei und justizbehörden dass dieses
problem zu fassen bekommen
nachvollziehen können es darf zum
beispiel nicht passieren dass es
durchaus heute noch gibt dass leute
gerade frauen zur polizei gehen legen
hass nachrichten und dann so was zu
hören bekommen wie na ja mach halt mal
vom wochenende das handy aus das heißt
das ist der erste bereich der zweiten
gesetzlichen fragen die wir gerade
angesprochen haben die sind sehr viel
klarere gemeinsame regelungen vermelde
und löscht verfahren die glänzenden
stelle die wir angesprochen haben und
auch sanktionsmechanismen wichtig und
drittens ist der ganze bereich der
prävention und der bereich der
unterstützung von betroffenen
wir haben gemerkt hatten ja herr
lauterbach und frau zu löwen darüber
gesprochen das ist auch unglaublich viel
stress mit dem man da konfrontiert ist
und es gibt unterstützt organisationen
die die menschen dabei unterstützen zum
beispiel hey tate und die mobile
beratung gegen rechts
diese müssen aber sehr viel besser
ausgestattet werden und projekt
unabhängig langfristig auch mit
staatlichen geldern mitfinanziert werden
sollen
vielen dank für ihre ansichten und für
ihre einschätzungen und damit mache ich
jetzt dank steam auch nochmal zu aber
nicht ohne noch mal wir haben es ja
gerade schon gehört aufhält dort ort
hinzuweisen eine wichtige organisation
an die man sich wenden kann wenn man
selber betroffen ist die helfen auch zb
dabei eine anzeige zu erstellen wenn man
sich tatsächlich so bedroht fühlt da mal
hingehen und jetzt möchte ich gern noch
mal dass meine kollegen kurz auf diesem
rechner schalten weil wenn ich hier so
drauf gucke dann wende ich mich jetzt
einfach mal genau an euch die ihr uns
den ganzen stream hiermit wirklich
teilweise widerlichen nachrichten voll
gesperrt hat ich weiß nicht was genau in
eurem leben schief gelaufen ist aber ich
kann nur sagen es tut mir leid für euch
dass sie nichts besseres zu tun hat als
euren abend damit zu verbringen so einen
müll herein zu schreiben bitte
suchthilfe und mit diesem sinne sage ich
jetzt in dieser kamera macht den stream
zu und sagt bis zum nächsten mal
macht gut
[Musik]